and you should be live chairman
thank you very much good evening welcome
to this council meeting on thursday
the 17th of december 2020
my name is councillor mark hurd and i'm
chairman of the malden district council
first of all please ensure your
microphones
remains muted and your video feed off
when not addressing the council
this will reduce background noises and
avoid
any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in the
meeting
you are giving consent to being recorded
during each item please use the chat
function of the meeting to indicate you
wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
any other purpose
please don't use the raise hand function
as this is not available
on all member devices
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference the page
or paragraph number so members if you
need to leave the meeting at any point
please do make this known and use the
chat function to signify
that you need to leave the meeting now
if i may ask
officers taking part in the meeting to
introduce themselves
and i'll start with mr dodson because i
think mr holmes is not present
good evening members paul dodson
director strategy performance and
governance
thank you mr leslie
good evening chris leslie director of
resources
thank you mr quelch uh
good evening uh simon quelch and i'm one
of the council's legal advisors
thank you mr holly
good evening members i'm grant holly i'm
the lead ict specialist
thank you very much mrs holmes
are you there emma oh
good evening council ahead
well done can you hear me okay yes i can
hear you fine okay
thank you very much could you just
introduce yourself and your title
sorry yeah i'm emma holmes i'm the legal
specialist thank you thank you very much
mr butcher
good evening members uh stephen butcher
commercial manager
thank you steven uh and miss bird
thank you chairman good evening members
tara bird committee services officer
thank you
thank you very much are there any other
officers present
thank chairman i'm matt lee lead
specialist
place thank you mr lee
very good to see you um tara please can
you now carry out a roll call of members
to confirm
who is it in attendance thank you uh yes
chairman thank you members
if he could just indicate your
attendance when i call your name please
starting with councillor bassinger
please
good evening everyone i'm present thank
you
councillor miss feel
yes present thank you councillor brian
bill
president good evening everybody that's
the bell
i'm present good evening everybody thank
you
councillor boyce
councillor voice not pleasant councillor
mrs channer
hello tara hi yes i'm present good
evening chairman and good evening
everybody
good evening evening thank you uh
councillor edwards
thank you good evening i'm president uh
good evening everyone thank you
casa fluka
good evening tyler yes i'm here thank
you thank you
council heard it councillor hull
good evening tara and good evening
everybody
i'm here good evening thank you
councillor jarvis
good evening tara chairman members
good morning thank you councillor keys
good evening tara good evening chairman
good evening everybody i'm present
good evening thank you cancer lagon
yeah present tara good evening everybody
i'm here thank you
councillor mays present tara
castle morley
greetings and ho ho ho thank you very
much
counsellor nunn uh yes good evening tara
good evening chairman good evening
everyone council shawnee
um good evening tara thank you i'm here
good evening everyone
good evening chairman thank you good
evening
good evening to our present and a merry
christmas merry christmas thank you
councillor schemes uh yes and merry
christmas for everybody
uh hello tara thank you very much
councillor stamp
yeah good evening chairman good evening
tara good evening members and
harry happy merry christmas as well
thank you good evening thank you
councillor stilts good evening tara good
evening members
uh merry christmas to you all i'm
present thank you very much
councillor swain yes good evening
everyone pleasant
good evening thank you councillor mrs
thompson
thank you cara present good evening
everyone good evening
good evening thank you and council miss
white
good evening tara i'm present and merry
christmas to everybody
and i hope you're looking forward to i
certainly am
thank you very much chairman thank you
that concludes the role call
thank you tara uh may uh may i have any
apologies for absence please
uh yes chairman apologies have been
received from cancer dewitt councillor
durham
council for mrs fleming and councillor
helm thank you
okay that's noted thank you very much
agenda item number three
uh of interest this is to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interest
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat function now to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
uh tara do we have any declarations
please
yes chairman council mrs channel has
indicated she has a declaration
thank you councillor tanner
uh thank you very much chairman um just
to indicate uh my normal one chairman
that i must declare i'm
also a member of essex county council
that is a non-pecu
pecuniary declaration chairman and it
does apply to a fair number of items on
the agenda
um namely probably mostly 11
12 because there are connections with
county
um 13 possibly 14 15
not 16 or 17 likely but uh certainly
um could be in terms of um 20
and 21 as well chairman so it's most
items where
um i've just highlighted thank you okay
that's noted thank you very much indeed
council channel
um any other declarations tara uh yes
chairman uh we have councillor lagan and
then councillor none
thank you thank you councillor
thank you chairman yeah just the
declaration gender item number 11
non-pecuniary
i've had some correspondence with people
in the bradwell district
thank you chair that's noted thank you
and councillor none
well i'm not sure about this one
chairman it doesn't directly relate to
eleven but i ought to be
uh up front and say that i'm now the
patron of the bradwell
raf bradwell bay preservation group um
thank you very much not pecuniary
thank you i also see um councillor
white's
hand is raised councillor white uh
thank you mr chairman i'd like to
declare an interest in gender item 21
which is the so mari's great war
aerodrome as i sit on the consultative
closet committee
and i also believe that i sit on the
bradwell
um village council committee so i i'm
not sure what there's the new committee
i've been put on to but i want to
declare it just in case it comes up
thank you okay i presume that's
non-pecuniary
absolutely both non-pecuniary thank you
very much
um i have one other note here councillor
shaunicy
um thank you chairman um yes item 11
please non-pecuniary
um i have had a correspondence from uh
residents in bradwell
thank you thank you councillor shaw
honestly uh any other declarations
please tara
no chairman that's all i have listed
thank you
thank you very much all of those are
duly noted
uh agenda item four are minutes
of the town council meeting uh held on
the
fifth of november this year uh it's
recommend
it's recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 5th of november and
they're found on pages
7 to 42 are approved as a true and
accurate record i so if you wish to
second the motion
please turn on your video unmute your
microphone
and state your name now please
councillor carly mays second
councillor carly mayes thank you very
much if any member wishes to raise
any matter of accuracy please use the
chat function to indicate
and i will invite you to speak um i see
that uh councillor chana
has indicated she was to speak cancer
channel
yes thank you very much chairman it's in
relation actually chairman sort of page
19 page 20
and where um the jsc the decision making
had to go back into full council
uh because as you'll be aware there was
an equality of votes
um when it was in the special meeting of
that committee
um you may recall chairman there was a
lot of bit of confusion really
councillor banff made points
about what should happen as she read the
constitution
um in that she thought the proposal has
to be had to be that as aligned with
what that took place in the special
committee
and then the monitoring officer mr
quelch the legal advisor came in
and said a new proposal but that was
after council and none had already come
in
and made a proposal but on the on the
clarification given
then councillor fleming made a proposal
um in my name chairman
and if you recall then um what you
decided was
um uh you said that you would proceed
with the council of passenger proposal
from councillor none
and in the event that failed then you
would go to the other proposal but
none of that chairman i know it's not
verbatim but i think it's quite
important
um to highlight the fact there was um
councillor fleming did propose after the
clarification had been given after all
the confusion by the monitoring officer
about the process
thank you thank you
do other members wish for that to be
included in the minutes
to agree chairman i would yeah yeah
really agree okay so uh if
if councilman wishes to make an
amendment
um i think we can
i think we can do that
sorry my mouse seems to have stopped
are we happy to to note that tara
and chairman we just need to know that
if we are going to add something or
amend it i
just need to be clear exactly what it is
we're adding an amending if that's
possible please
well it's about the proposal prior to
the um
monitoring officer giving the clarity
about the process
um and um and then saying that there's a
proposal had to be done in that meet
uh meeting of council um council and
under already proposed
when mr quelch gave his clarification
councillor fleming made a proposal in my
name the chairman
took council of passengers in the name
of councillor nunn
that was the proposal and said that if
that failed then he would go to the
other proposal
it's on the tape i think the tape
explains it actually
have you managed to uh to write that uh
tara
um chairman i haven't got all of that
i'm sure i can pick it up i'm just a bit
what i'm just trying to identify is
exactly
um where it is in the minutes we're
adding that and what we're actually
going to add
i don't mean to um well about the
proposal that counselor fleming made in
the light of the monitoring officer
explaining another proposal had to come
from the chamber ahead of that council
and none have made a proposal in the
name of bassinger
but there was the confusion you didn't
put the bidding about council bamford
coming in
or anything like that but councillor
fleming did and then
the chairman said well we'll go with the
council of passenger in the name of
council and none and if that then failed
then the other one it's the last part of
the tape actually terror on on that
meeting
i mean if you like i can get a verbatim
what was said
yes i think that's sorry um i was just
going to suggest perhaps um
if if members would agree to the minutes
subject to that amendment and we can
agree the wording outside of the meeting
if that's suitable for you yes agreed
do you have any other points counselor
jenna on that
no thank you chairman okay can we agree
those minutes by
sent then please members
thank you very much indeed we'll move on
then
to agenda item five public questions and
i can advise that we have not received
any questions
from the public agenda item number six
chairman's announcements i've just got
just got
a couple of announcements to make first
of all
i congratulate councillor penny chana
who has been chosen as the leader
new leader of the opposition i very much
appreciate her comments that i read in
the paper today
and i look forward to us all working
together
um earlier this week um i hosted
a staff christmas quiz on tuesday
there were 55 participants
um and it seemed to go down very well
and well done to
melissa curtis uh who was the uh who was
the clear winner
uh the third item is that counselor nun
and i earlier this week
um attended uh a dementia friends
training session um this
is something which quite
shocked me in that 25 percent
of the coved deaths have been linked
to dementia and it is likely to affect
one in three of us directly or
indirectly
there is a new training session which is
being planned for the 20th of january
10 until 11 30 for members
and i recommend that members
do tune into that it is a real
eye-opener
um we'll move on now to agenda item
number seven
uh which is the minute book uh strategy
and resources committee
on the 19th of november 2020
this is on pages 43-52
and councillor siddal to present the
minutes please councillor siddall
thank you chairman
chairman i present the minutes of the
strategy and resources committee meeting
held remotely
on the 19th of november 2020 found on
pages 43-52
and proposed their reception and
adoption
could i have a second to please i'll
second that counselor wendy stamp
thank you councillor sam so i would just
like to go through those pages so
pages 43
44 45
46 47
48 49
50 51 and 52
iso move
thank you councillor siddal can we agree
those members by
sent please please please
agreed agreed
thank you very much uh the second part
is
the strategy and resources committee
special meeting on the 24th of november
2020
this is containing pages 53-156
um i'm not sure you have to go through
all of those councils
but uh could i ask you to present the
minutes and the four recommendations
contained
in the uh the minute numbers please oh
well hopefully i'm not going to count
from 53 to 156.
chairman i present the minutes of the
strategy resources committee meeting
held remotely on the 24th of november
2020
found on pages 53-156
i propose their reception and adoption
could i have a second to please
second second chairman thank you
so on page 54
minute 91 it policies
now members should note should these be
agreed
the following items will be added on the
second page
of the info information security policy
because these items were missed off and
that is to conduct their business
in accordance with this policy take
responsibility for familiarizing
themselves
with this policy and understand the
obligations
it places on them then on page
56 minute 92
planning enforcement page
57 before we go any further
i think counselor channel has a question
on page 56 council
okay yes thank you very much chairman
sorry at first i thought it was 54.
it's difficult when you're trying to
look at things and and then do this at
the same time
um chairman is in relation to the
recommendation little too and about the
enforcement policy
and i do refer to some of the texts and
um you'll see under one of the bullet
points that mr lee did confirm that
members would be consulted
regarding enforcement notices i was
quite concerned about that when we had
the debate at the committee chairman
because the um flow chart didn't reveal
that now
i've discovered what happened in 2015
the policy
of march 2015 did have the full flow
chart in where it showed actually
another part of the flowchart where
members were included it was under the
heading
uh breach of planning control
established and at the end it was quite
clear and meant about
informing ward councillors of action
then for some reason in march 2018
another policy
reflecting much on that old policy of
march 2015 was there and for some reason
the flow chart
wasn't in that and i don't know if that
accounts for the reason
as to why i may not or others may not
other counsellors i mean not just me
are not getting necessarily enforcement
notices before they're served that's
normally the procedure
now the thing that worries me about the
policy chairman could you just give me
the assurance because it is silent
on the fact that members the process and
um protocols will still include members
before the enforcement notices we are we
we
will be informed of them ahead
of them going out as was previous and i
allude to the bullet point mr lee seems
to be
saying that but nowhere in the new
policy does
is that covered about the members
involvement and that was my point i was
also
always trying to make up strategy and
resources so can i be given that
assurance
i obviously want to agree the policy but
i need to know that assurance
that members will still be consulted
about the enforcement notices
just ahead they just see them chairman
should we call mr lee
mr lee can you help with that thank you
chairman um
happy to assist um
um my oh i think we debated this point
at quite length on the evening
um and the planning policy as i said
the old one we had was multi-layered it
was policy it was guidance it was
a number of facts and the current
proposes to ship that down to only have
the policy
specifically the the internal processes
that we do
will not sit within the policy they sit
within the what used to be called the
yearbook i'm not sure if it's been
updated the title
um and that hasn't changed it's it's
very similar to looking at like
our ldp and our scheme of delegation the
policies like the ldp
and the requirement to consult members
before the enforcement notice goes out
is through similar to the scheme of
delegation it was a planning application
and so that will not be changing um i
think it's called constitution now
um yes it's been updated that yeah so
i'm showing my age but um
so yeah so i might get and i i know
council channel did
raise this issue about not being
insulted i had asked um
that to be highlighted if we had done
any uh enforcement notices for her so
the
i think it's probably like we haven't
actually served any notice recently
in her ward and that's why she won't
have been informed of any
but they all members will be informed
yeah as always yeah that's not changing
thank you
thank you mr lee okay thank you mr lee
um
council channel you wanted to come back
on that well thank you chairman yes i
did i hope made it clear i was seeking
assurance i said the policy needed to be
agreed i was just seeking that assurance
because it was minuted under a bullet
point that mr lee said members would be
but
it's silent and he's now explained but
just to ensure
um that was the case but that assurance
has now been given at council so um
i'm sure that will be minuted and i'm
happy with that chairman thank you i
think it's been quite important for all
members though
thank you very much i think uh i think
councillor sidle perhaps if we go
through the minutes first and then come
back to the recommendations
okay so i go back to page 56
minute 92 planning enforcement
page 57 minute 91
north key development brief
supplementary planning document
and page 60 minute 99
document retention policy
i say move
thank you very much tara
has any members um indicated they wish
to speak
hey chairman
great chairman okay we're happy to agree
those uh
those i propose we agree check it out
we've got to go to the recommendations
first now haven't we
cancer uh so
the recommendations are that uh
minute 91 it policies uh with the
amendment to
be um agreed and minute 91 playing
enforcement
uh the statement to be
agreed and the north key development
brief supplementary plan document
to be agreed and the document retention
policy to be agreed
proposed chairman to agree
sorry cancer channel i didn't catch that
i was proposing we agree it was
proposing councillor siddal's rex
and thank you councillor siddall
we now move on to c performance
governance
and audit committee this is on the 26th
of november
2020 this has been circulated
separately and is found in the
supplementary pack
on pages three and eight and councillor
stilts
to present the minutes councillor stilts
thank you mr chairman i present the
minutes of the performance governance
and audit committee meeting held
remotely on the 26th of november 2020
found on pages three to eleven of the
supplementary pack
and proposed their reception and
adoption
can i have a second
second second ladies chairman thank you
for jarvis thank you captain jarvis
i give you page three page
four page five
page six page seven
page eight page nine
page 10 and page 11
so i move
thank you very much sorry tara i
couldn't quite get your message on the
on the pga
um no no no problem chairman it was just
that your chairman chat referred to the
wrong page numbers that's all
but council stilts has referred to the
correct ones thank you thank you very
much indeed
uh once again members are we happy to
agree that those by ascent
agreed
thank you very much uh we're moving on
now to
agenda item number eight minutes of
meeting of the council
and this is to note that since the last
meeting of the council
and up until wednesday the 9th of
december 2020
council agenda dispatch the committees
listed
have met and to receive any questions in
accordance with council
and committee procedure rule 6-2 if any
member wishes to raise a question in
relation to the minutes of this meeting
please make this known by using the chat
function
within this meeting
tara has anyone indicated they wish to
speak
uh chairman councillor skins as
indicated you wish to speak
uh just to say that uh of all of those
the only one that hasn't met is the
south east area planning committee
because
there hasn't been any business for it or
business arrived and then disappeared so
apart from that just so i've made that
clear
thank you very much indeed um in that
case um
these are to be uh noted uh
uh again our members happy to note that
noted thank you very much uh
we move on now to agenda item nine
and this is a statement from the leader
of the council
setting out the council's report and
program
for the remainder of the municipal year
leader please make your statement
thank you thank you chairman my fellow
councillors
members of the public and press i
present to you as the elected leader of
modern district council
the council's report and program for the
remainder of the municipal year
it is a huge honor and privilege to
represent the district as its new
independent council leader it means a
great deal to me
and all the elected independent
councillors that won their seats
in may 2019 and the high number of
residents who voted for change
thank you for giving us this opportunity
and believe me we do not intend to waste
it
i personally wish to thank councillor
stephen nunn my first class deputy
who has also hit the ground running
what happens in modern district happens
what happens in modern district
matters to me the people we work with
the people we work for and the people we
serve
regardless of our differences this is
the one thing that unites us all
we have the responsibility of looking
after the modern district and leaving a
positive legacy
we have already demonstrated how we want
to work together
for the benefit of the residents by
being inclusive
we should all show kindness respect to
each other
and recognize everyone's qualities and
values
the independent administration of this
council is keen to change malden
district council
and importantly how the council has been
perceived
recently following the last few months
of
turmoil that does not mean we are going
to rip up all the policies
that have gone before we will look to
keep what is good
and to make the necessary changes in a
balanced and measured way
we will challenge and seek to change
what currently
appears to be inconvenient to the system
whether that is excessively slow
responses from our partners
or that's how it has always been done we
will look at strengthening
and revising parts of our constitution
including our code of conduct
ensuring that even if something may not
be deemed illegal
it could be ill-advised and reflect
negatively on our council as a whole
we need to ensure integrity openness and
transparency
we will look to improve working in
partnership with our communities
listening to our residents and focusing
on providing
excellent excellent customer service we
will build on the great partnerships
that already exist we recognize how
effective partnership
working has been um helps excuse me
chairman
we recognize how effective partnership
working has been in dealing with the
covid response
the covered response across the modern
district
has been fantastic there has been that
has been because
organizations have worked together
whether that is the district council our
partners in the voluntary
sector health providers police
county council town and parish councils
and the communities themselves with
common purpose and understanding of each
other's roles and strengths
we have been able to provide more
support and work together
better than ever it is that cooperative
shared approach
we want to take forward with our partner
organizations
and our communities with that in mind we
will be looking to develop
and update our corporate plan we are
keen to build on the current work the
council is delivering
but with a renewed focus in key areas
including climate and environment we
will be bringing forward a climate
emergency declaration
early in the new year and will then
establish a climate and environment
strategy to follow
economic recovery we will focus on
working with our businesses to help them
recover from the current challenges
and to enable the district economy to
thrive creating new jobs
commercial strategy and financial
stability
this is paramount and we will be taking
a more business commercial approach to
future proof
and safeguard the council for the future
strengthening communities and enabling
them to thrive
recognizing how well we work together
this year
and capturing that approach to deliver
wider benefits
i have embraced the leadership role and
have loved working more closely with the
officers
who are full of ideas and energy
teamwork is essential for the council to
feel
free and comfortable to voice
suggestions
no matter how extreme or sometimes
unpopular they may be
i have attended numerous meetings
watching an excellent scrum meeting
enabling cross-team support ideas
actions
tasks and important updates from the for
the benefit of the whole district
i was extremely impressed so many new
ideas in the pipeline
which will be brought to the council in
the future i hope
our offices work exceptionally hard and
sometimes i feel this need
there is a need for this to be
publicised and recognized more
directors and officers are working with
members and our partners to make modern
district a better place to live
to work and to visit i would like to
thank the offices and support staff
for all their hard work not only through
the transformation
but this year dealing with the kovid
pandemic it would not be fair to single
out any one team
as they are just that a team having
faced and still
facing huge challenges and extra work
they have taken on
as well as operating business as usual
finally
i am proud to present and live in the
malden district
and i hope my leaders speech has
empowered you
and inspired you to share my vision to
demonstrate that we are
a professional hard working council that
cares
thank you chairman thank you very much
thank you leader now the leader of
the opposition now has the right to
reply
counselor channel uh
oh thank you for that chairman i thought
the leader's statement was just that a
statement
i wasn't clear from the constitution it
did say that
but i would just say chairman i think
the council certainly my time on it we
all have all worked for the best
interests
of the district and that does involve
partnership working
and i appreciate um what the leader has
said about climate change coming forward
and i believe there was a strategy i
believe mr geller
is working very hard on a climate change
strategy so i welcome that
and i think i must say because i have
mentioned it in a statement i gave
actually to the press i think we have
shared all of us
the awful situation the pandemic has
brought along
for our residents but also the county
and the country
and i think that it has shown how
working with our neighbors and
in partnership and also the people in
the district the voluntary services
what can be done and i would actually
like to herald
the innovative actions this authority
has taken in making sure
we do keep delivering the best services
for the for the district which i think
that the leader was referring to
and i do acknowledge and i complement
and i do applaud our excellent officers
who actually have worked i would say
round the clock to ensure
um they keep this district really
uh having the services that it does need
and looking after the interests of our
residents to the best of everyone's
abilities during these difficult
challenging times
and where there have been problems i
think they've been sorted out as quickly
as possible
and i think i must say uh the community
uh document that was produced
information document and that was by and
i will name an officer
mr ben brown was absolutely excellent it
was updated regularly and i think that's
what
the leader may be referring to as well
working with our communities and we
relied very much
on the parishes um to make sure that
information also
uh was put out to the residents of the
district and
i want to thank my parishes and all
those in the district that actually have
helped
in terms of making sure the vulnerable
um
which the elderly often were sort of
not left to flounder on their own and
various things
like mills and that i know were
happening in my ward
as i'm sure elsewhere so i do
acknowledge the leaders speech i wasn't
expecting to do this i thought it was a
statement
rather than i thought it was the budget
where i had the opportunity to speak
but i do thank you for that opportunity
chairman and i acknowledge the leader
speech and all the points that she makes
and um i'm glad to see that the
partnership working
and other areas will be continued going
forward um the leader has said by the um
independent administration
thank you chairman thank you for that uh
councillor channel
uh is there leader you you do have a
right of reply is there anything else
you wish to add
um i do have a right to reply thank you
chairman
um i think it would be inappropriate to
reply at this stage
because i'm really positive i take on
board what the opposition leader said
but it hasn't always been the case and
that my statement was
hopefully that we will keep moving
forward
and hopefully everybody will continue to
work together so thank you for the right
to reply thank you
thank you very much indeed um
members i is everybody happy to move on
to agenda item number ten
yes yes thank you very much this is
questions given in accordance with
procedure rule six three of which notice
has been given and i convey i can advise
that we have not received any questions
in according in accordance with this
procedure rule
i therefore will move on to agenda item
11.
this is the brad bradwell b power
station working group recommendation
uh which relates to a letter of support
for small modular reactors
uh this is found on pages 157 to 160.
in a moment i will call on the leader to
present
this item uh members reminder that if
you wish to speak on this item please
make this known by using the chat
function
within the meeting i will then come to
you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succinct leader please can you introduce
the report
yes thank you chairman the purpose of
the report
it is to consider the recommendation of
the bradwell b
power station working group that's a
letter of support
for the ongoing development of small
modular reactors be sent to john
whittingdale obe
mp and to steven speed director of
nuclear
at the department for business energy
and industrial strategy
chairman if you just allow me before you
put the recommendation just to say
and to remind members it is really
healthy that the working group
is bringing to this council this view
it has been discussed in the working
group and i think it's only right that
any member is allowed to bring
something for debate or a recommendation
to the council it has to be considered
um
i do want to say though chair and i want
to remind everybody we're not the
decision makers
for whether we receive more nuclear
development in the district we can only
attempt to
influence the impacts by lobbying
government
in terms of scale of this and by our
engagement through the consent order
process
um i'd like to hand over if mr dodson
has anything to add but i'm really
grateful that this report has come to
council
and that we have the opportunity to have
a small debate chair
within the rules of the constitution and
then you make the recommendation
thank you thank you mr johnson
thank you chairman um yes as the leader
of the council said this is a report on
on behalf
of the bradwell b power station working
group
and the the working groups fully aware
that small modular reactor
technology is not a part of brb's
proposals for the site
however in light of concerns about the
scale of the current proposals
and the associated scale of likely
effects
the working group felt that should the
current proposals for a power station
fall aside
for whatever reason and that the
government continues to consider
bradwell b
as a potentially suitable site for new
nuclear development
that smr technology could be considered
as an option for the bradwell b
site in preference to conventional
nuclear development
members are being asked to take a vote
on submitting a letter to the mp john
whittingdale
and to steven steven speed nuclear
director at bayes
to state that if a number of things
occur that lead to the site still being
designated for nuclear development
that the council supports a smaller
scale development as proposed by the
potential small modular reactor design
from rolls-royce
instead of another larger scale
development this was recommended by
members of the october 20th bradwell b
member working group
thank you thank you mr dodson
well the recommendation is set out in
the report as follows
that the letter of support for the
ongoing development of small modular
reactors
be sent to john whittingdale um obe
mp and to stephen speed director of
nuclear
department for business energy and
industrial strategy
so um if we wish to speak about this
uh if any member wishes to second the
motion in order that we can debate this
please second second
thank you councillor maze i i took your
one first
uh i would now invite members to make
any comments
on the report uh but i would ask members
to bear in mind that this
is for a letter of support to be sent
or not um tara has anyone indicated they
wish to speak
please uh yes chairman i have a few i
have counsellor lagan cancer swaying
councillor schemes and council mrs
channel
thank you
thank you very much councillor lagan
yeah thank you very much chair um first
of all thanks to
the to the working group for for
spending the time to look at
looking at options is appreciated
i have concerns about actually
supporting
smr technology and within the within the
letter
it talks about the advantages of smr
um when those advantages really aren't
clear on technology that that really
isn't proven
uh and the the type of design of smrs
that we've got at the moment haven't
even gone through the design principle
so we're looking at the technology that
we don't
really know about but what we do know is
that smrs are not small
and they are modular and they are
reactors they produce heat and waste and
that's about it
and the infrastructure that it
degenerates um could
if it was to be considered down at
bradwell uh resulting in even in greater
space being taken down on that beautiful
peninsula
um there's also funding issues that you
know are within the government but
that's a government
issue um that's not really going to be
um
supported whether we talk about the 250
million being reduced to 100 million for
for its um its uh development
so really when i looked at this i i
looked at it with a very much an open
mind
and it struck me as we were we're
supporting something
and i use the analogy about we want to
build a swimming pool for the loch ness
monster
but we don't know how big it is and we
don't know if it actually exists
and i think if we if we went out to
support smrs on this site we'll be doing
exactly that
and uh i feel what we should do is is
hold back
see what the the process brings as it
goes forward
um we don't know what technology is
going to occur in the future
and if the site's still designated in
time to come then we need to cross that
bridge when we come to it
but we shouldn't really be looking at
something that we don't know enough
about at this point in time which could
have catastrophic effects
as much as the same as the large planned
development by brp
that's yeah thank you very much indeed
councillor
councillor swain
yes sir thank you chairman
um first of all i'm no i'm not in favor
of nuclear power
but then i don't think we as a country
have been serious enough about
obviating the need for it and if we look
at what's happening down in somerset
it's quite clear that nuclear power is
going to be
part of the energy mix for quite a long
time
now when it comes to these small modular
reactors
and rolls royce have stated quite
recently publicly
in a prospectus for additional funds
that they expected to be able to
provide electricity to the grid from our
modular reactor by
2029 even if this is
vaguely optimistic um it would still
seem to be
in advance of when we could expect any
electricity generated from a very large
nuclear power station
at bradwell and i think it is in the
national interest
that we push ahead with trying to make
um
with r d to try and make these small
modular reaction reactors
a viable proposition and a viable
alternative
to very large stations
for various reasons one of which is
that they could be distributed in
different locations
and we wouldn't be restricted to the
very small number of sites
that the government has had to look at
um
but as far as bradwell is concerned i
don't think it's
um appropriate it's not an alternative
um i don't think there's any indication
that we were saying well we would prefer
a small modular reactor we wouldn't um
it's still a significant industrial
development and the brad
bradwell and the denji peninsula really
is not suited to
a power station of any scale nuclear
um of the type of planned or in the
small moderators
in fact it's not really but can i just
remind you
that what we're talking about is whether
you should or shouldn't send a letter of
support yes
right could you try and keep to that
please
and well that's why i say that we are
we are supporting this or we are urging
um the government to put more
effort behind um this
idea in the national interest
and we have a right to be involved in
that because we malden
um i was in the front line of this whole
debate about where we're going with
nuclear power
thank you thank you very much council
swain councillor schemes
hello yes thank you chairman um i think
we should send this letter
uh my major concern about bradwell is
the fact that the current proposal
has a group of the largest buildings in
essex
in the flattest most one of the most uh
rural areas of essex and that just
cannot happen
we've got to do what we can to get this
scale
down i believe that a small
modular reactor um which is uh being led
with british technology by rolls-royce
would be
a far better option and as uh councillor
swain was pointing out
the whole point of small modular
reactors is that they can be
spread uh across the country that we
wouldn't have to have
five on our site to um
equal the cut the proposed output at
bradwell
because the whole point is that they can
be spread across the country
uh i've personally speaking personally
and in reaction to residents comments
i would prefer that there isn't a
massive nuclear site
i do believe that the site is
inappropriate for such a
massive development and so i am in short
in support of uh encouraging this
new technology thank you very much
uh for that uh so we've got quite a few
members who wish to speak so
uh please please be uh as succinct as
you can
uh i'll go next to councillor chana
thank you very much chairman i'm not
really going to dwell on
the bradwell situation as such because
obviously it's not a matter to a
discussion
it's about actually this letter of
support
going for the smrs well i'd just like to
say i do actually think the officers
report
and i i'm going to refer to paragraphs
3.3.2
and 3.3.3 are very succinct and clear
what this is about
and it was just saying about the support
should
for any reason the proposals that may be
going um
forward and we can't we we can't
determine those chairman as we know
yes we can be involved in the process
that um
and the site then should still be seen
as being suitable for a nuclear site
then
that's why the sort of smr agenda but i
would like to point out chairman it's
also
in the energy white paper the government
have highlighted
um about smrs but also i'd like it i
think we ought to determine
use the term knowledge well advanced
technology because they've also bought
the policy document out
which covers smr and advanced technology
and when you look at what this
could really mean in terms of smls and
i'm not just talking about us actually
chairman
i'm talking about things across the
whole country and bearing in mind what
the aim is
by the government you know regarding
um emissions being reduced and
everything and
climate change it will be these smrs
could be a benefit
in other areas for the reasons that you
can have um
on smaller sites and elsewhere and we
know our energy requirements
so i think the government's documents
i've just referred to do actually cover
it off
and they are investing in um sort of
this technology to proceed it's an
innovation
and they're going to provide up to 385
million
in advanced nuclear fund for the next
generation of nuclear technology
aimed to be by early 2030s developed the
smrs and to build advanced
modular reactors a demonstrator because
we're a leader in those technologies
and for those reasons i think actually
the recommendation is just very clear
it's a letter of support to support that
ongoing smr
um you know innovation whatever work
needs to be done chairman
so i i would support
thank you very much indeed um councillor
morley i think uh you did want to speak
but
have you withdrawn that now um
yes it's okay it was really
um i think it's kind of sort of been
nice i just really wanted to know
how many we actually needed these
smaller ones to
uh replace bradford and things like that
i would just
be interested to know those sort of
things and
um yeah just really on that it's been
answered though i think thank you
all right thank you very much uh council
of bassinger i think you're next
thank you mr chairman um all i'd like to
say is in regard to this letter
i don't think it matters what we write
in this lesson how
how we put or we discuss smrs or
whatever
at the end of the day the only thing
they're looking for and the only thing
that will be dug out of any letter
is that mdc if we send it supports
nuclear power i don't think they're
interested particularly in our views
all they're waiting for is a little
niche a little crack to say
mdc supports nuclear power and because
of that
i totally reject the idea of sending any
letters of
any support for any form of nuclear
power thank you mr chairman
okay thank you very much um councillor
morris
thank you chairman um councillor
passenger has just literally
uh got the whole thing right i don't
think we should be sending any letters
of support they won't be read they will
just be spun
what they'll say is that we support
nuclear power
i i personally i don't support nuclear
power i don't think it's good for the
district
um i don't believe we should send any
letter supporting any nuclear power
thank you okay thank you very much um
tara are there any other speakers who
have indicated they wish to
uh contribute to this uh no chairman
that's the point i've got on the list
thank you very much
thank you very much i will allow um
councillor councillor lagan
i know that you've looked into this a
lot uh are you
you have asked to come back and i will
allow a very quick
second bite thank you
it will be very very quick and i
appreciate it just something for members
to consider the
recent debates we're looking at changing
potentially reviewing our position on
nuclear power in the ldp
and development at bradwell so it may be
so
slightly hypocritical of us um if we do
so and i think
again council passenger has actually
nailed it
thank you well done thank you very much
i
see that uh councillor shaughnessy would
like to speak on this as you haven't
spoken before
um councillor seancy thank you very much
um
chairman i don't i don't think my
previous message sent properly
um so i'm i'm sorry if i'm holding um
our proceedings but i will be very quick
um
the um working group that decided about
this letter is not the current working
group the bradwell working group i would
like to point that out thank you
and these small reactors
still would cause
environmental environmental destruction
there would still be
huge radioactive waste which
is a problem um and i wouldn't wish
this on bradwell or the surroundings any
more than i would
the proposed brad will be that's all i
wish to say chairman thank you very much
thank you very much um are there any
other speakers at all tara
no chairman thank you very much well
members
this letter is uh this recommendation is
for
a letter of support uh for the ongoing
development of
smrs to be sent to our np and to the
director of nuclear um
uh nuclear energy um
i think as there are no speakers i think
perhaps we can take this
to the vote now
uh could we record that recorded please
second is council bell okay so we've
we've had a request for a recorded vote
from councillor bassinger
it has been seconded by councillor bell
um
tara could you take the vote please
uh yes chairman uh members um i'm gonna
call your name could you please indicate
if you are for against or abstaining and
this
is the vote in relation to sending a
letter of support
um regarding the small modular reactors
thank you chairman starting with
councillor bassinder please
against thank you councilman
or councillor brian bill
or bell
against uh council mrs channel
poor because it's not saying we agree
with nuclear
cancer edwards four thank you councillor
fluker
against councillor heard
i'll abstain thank you councillor ho
for jarvis
against castle keys
paul morris
against thank you councillor none
against that's the shauna c
against councillor siddal
for cancer schemes
smaller a smaller better technology is
better for
that's a stamp
i'm going against
against you councillor swain
paul thank you councillor mrs thompson
for thank you and councillor miss white
or please tara thank you chairman the
results of that are 12
4 11 against and one abstention
thank you chairman thank you very much
uh in that case uh that is carried
and therefore uh we will send a letter
um of support uh
we'll move on now to uh agenda item
13. this is a report of the
corporate governance working group this
is found on pages 169
and in a moment i'll call it once again
on the leader to present
this item once again chair aren't we
doing
a gender item 12 tax base or is it me
have i made a mistake chair
you haven't met in fact i have made a
mistake
so thank you very much yeah agenda item
number 12
council tax base uh so in a moment i
will still call on the leader
um to present this item uh if you wish
to speak on this item please make this
known by using the chat function
and then i'll come to you in turn once
again members
please keep your points clear and
succinct
and leader please present the report
thank you chair
the purpose of the report is that the
council is required
to set the tax base for council tax by
the 31st of january
in the financial year proceeding that to
which the tax base
applies the council has to notify its
tax-based calculations to essex county
council essex fire authority and the
police and crime commissioners that
commissioner for essex
and parish and town councils by the 31st
of january
uh before you make the recommendation
leader
i don't know if mr leslie would like to
come in because to me the the um
report's quite straightforward thank you
thank you chair
thank you mr leslie
thank you chairman i do feel that the
leader has probably already
summed this up to be honest it is an
annual item that is presented to the
council every december
it sets out the council tax base for the
next year uh that in turn is used to
estimate uh the council tax income
as set out in the report the base has
decreased by nearly 132
and the equivalent properties compared
to this year
this is due to an increase in the
expected
demand for the local council tax support
scheme as well as a projected decrease
in collection
by 1.3 from this year all as a result of
the impacts of
kovid and this was partly offset by an
increase in the number of dwellings
anticipated to be added
uh to the valuation location list next
year however
thank you
thank you mr leslie um so the
recommendation
is uh set out within the report
as follows that in accordance with the
local authority's calculation of
tax-based regulations
the amount calculated by malden district
council has its tax base for the year
2021
shall be set as shown if any member
wishes to second that motion
please turn on your video unmute your
microphone and state your name now
second dude councillor wendy stamp
councillor wendy stamp thank you very
much
i'll now invite members to make any
comments on the report
tara has anybody indicated they wish to
speak please
uh no chairman we have nobody wishing to
speak
oh apologies counselor edwards would
like to speak
thank you councillor edwards uh
yes thank you chairman just a question
is
the tax base based on the number of
properties
as of the last month or two or last
october or november
thank you are you able to help with that
mr leslie
yes that's right it's both a number of
properties at the end of
uh october which obviously we adjust for
anticipated growth
and obviously we then do the changes in
collection as well as the local council
tax football scheme so it is based at
the end of
october on the properties can i come
back german so all the properties
occupied
after october are not included
uh that's the adjustment we we make we
look at the october one
so it's based on that initially and then
we adjust for those additional
properties
uh as well that we expect to come in the
next year
okay yes you can say it takes into
account the additional properties we
expect to come online next year
okay thank you thank you very much
um tara has anybody else
indicated they wish to speak
the recommendation chairman can we agree
that by sent members
agreed
i'll great my hand up all right okay
sorry i didn't see you there i'll come
back to you mr council morris
council appeal yes
the most important people to worry about
um the council tax are the actual
residents etc
i think the residents like to hear a lot
of talk about how it's going to be
uh calculated but i think it's most
important
that if we can give a guide or a steer
or an indication
of what is going to happen to the tax
onto the actual individuals next year
relative to this year is it going up by
a small percentage
large percentage or what can we give
that guy to anybody
celeste are you able to help on that
yeah so uh council tax increases
uh for this district uh capped at two
percent
so uh anything above or two center above
requires a
local referendum to be held uh setting
of the council tax base
is a council decision which will take
place
in february prior or subsequently to a
report going to
the snr committee in january but that's
really a member's decision
okay thank you very much uh councillor
morris
do you want to say something
thank you mr chairman i'd just like the
minutes to reflect my dissent
don't want a recorded vote or anything
on it and i'd just like to say that uh
we should all watch this space and
perhaps everyone should have a look at a
uh
a website called fairer share so just
want my descent noted on the minutes
please thank you
okay uh but i'm advised that uh if we
have
one descent uh we do have to have a roll
call
okay chair sorry to have to do this to
you guys um
let's have a roll call okay thank you
very much um are you able to do that
tara yes chairman of course okay
uh we'll go with that so uh
so you will either be for or against the
recommendation is that correct
yes chairman fought against you
explaining please starting a council
passenger please
four thank you tara thank you councilman
field
oh thank you councillor brian bill
thank you councillor bell for you
support uh council mrs channel oh this
is something we need to do thank you
thank you councillor edwards four
pinky council freaker
four head
yes i'm for this that's a whole
four thank you cancer jarvis
yes four thank you you cancer keys
four thank you cancer lagging
four please tara thank you councillor
mays
four thank you councillor morley
paul tara thank you councilman morris
okay thank you very much councillor nunn
for thank you council shawnee
four thank you tara council for
thank you cancer schemes oh
essentially a statement of fact thank
you councillor mrs thompson
councillors when you said it for me
thank you tara thank you council swain
for it's a legal requirement and council
miss white
four chairman the results of that are
twenty three
four and one against thank you thank you
very much
uh we'll move on now to agenda item 13
and this is the
report of the corporate governance
working group this is found on page 169
in a moment i'll call on the leader to
present this item
uh once again members please use the
chat function
and i will come to you in turn so please
keep
your points clear and to the point
leader please introduce the report thank
you chair
the purpose of this report members is to
provide information
and recommendations from the corporate
governance working group
meeting that took place on the 2nd of
december 2020
we've got an excellent working group and
our chairman of our working group is
councillor richard siddall and i'd like
to hand over to him with the support of
mr dodson if it's required
thank you councillor siddall thank you
leader
yes as the leader stipulates the
corporate uh governance working group
met on the second december
to consider the remote meeting protocol
in more detail
as agreed on the first of october
council meeting
because at that particular time the
council couldn't come to a decision
and a revised version has now been
produced
including further amendments from the
group and this is a as attached for
members for approval as appendix
a the group also considered some
additional constitution
and best practice matters and there are
some additional recommendations
which cover updates to procedure rule 10
institute in instituting a maximum
meeting length
scheduling ons as required rather than
regularly
these are included in recommendations
for member review with further
explanation as to how the working group
reached the recommendations within the
report
thank you chairman
thank you very much indeed so the
recommendations
are set out within the report as
follows recommendation
i think i'm not sure i've actually moved
those have i so we have the four
recommendations there
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
i'm mute your microphone
counce thank you very much and i will
now
invite members to make any comments
on the report tara has anyone indicated
they wish to speak please
and no chairman they haven't thank you
okay
uh in that case i will go to the
recommendations do members want to
vote for these uh on block all four
[Music]
i think councillor swaim was before me
chairman thank you very much councillor
swain
uh okay thank you councillor tanner um
yes my my first point is i believe this
should have been reported to
performance governance and audit if it
concerns governance
it should have gone and being considered
by that uh committee
rather than coming direct to council and
then these um
consideration recommendations could have
been chewed over a bit more than
just uh in a working group um
there was some my um
i do have a qualm about the fourth
recommendation on the overview and
scrutiny
um to not have any schedules any
meetings in the schedule
um it does seem to cause potential
problems because one then has to
have the problems of trying to convene
ad hoc meetings
so i would have thought it was advisable
to have certain meetings
but with the possibility of others being
injected um as necessary but to make
them all ad hoc
i think it's just uh going to make life
difficult organizing them
until i answer that chairman yes i was
going to come to you next um
yes as as chair of snr yes please
uh so the reason why the uh corporate
this report has gone from the working
group to full council
is that corporate working governance
group reports to full council
does not report to pga hence why i'm on
that group
as chairman of strategic resources so
therefore the correct process has
has followed in terms of uh reporting to
full council as as
the next step in terms of the the the
current six week cycle
in in terms of overview and scrutiny
those items often have to go away
and had a lot of work put into them so
it means that in terms of a work plan
therefore there needs to be that
flexibility rather than it being a rigid
that the overview security has to me on
on us on a six-week cycle
so it gives opportunity for those items
that are raised to be
fully investigated to go and have a look
at and then come back to the committee
at the relevant time the same thing
happens on planning
on the licensing committee it's only me
it's and the same with with
joint standards so therefore it's
actually meeting requirements more
effectively
for that particular committee that what
the council is trying to avoid
is what happened last year where lots of
meetings were cancelled
you know so there was a schedule for
them but a lot of those meetings were
cancelled
and then there came this question about
whether overview and scrutiny has a role
anymore
so we're trying to actually improve the
process
by introducing that particular
recommendation
yes thank you very much just um have you
ever
joined in on that i think the question i
think the question that you've posed
has been answered this way you know if
you're if you want to
uh speak on on something that counselor
civil has spoken about
as a point of clarification
but i think the question has been
answered because we're not talking just
about the overview and scrutiny
committee
but the working group of the committee
that filters
uh topics for consideration and that
would seem to be something to be handled
on a
regular basis so again that the same
principles apply because that working
group is
is works on the items that are put
forward by members
so i should imagine that when there are
several of those forms completed
and there are items to be to look at
whether they need to be scrutinized or
not
there's no point in scheduling a working
group when there's nothing to look or
all it ends up doing is being cancelled
so as soon as there are enough
of those item raised then the working
group will meet and therefore that will
then lead to the overview
scrutiny committee meeting so it's
actually making things easier
i will come to i will come to councillor
bell
as uh chair of over the inspiration in
just a moment
can i just go to councillor chana next
please
well i'm happy to give way to councillor
bell if you'd like as the chairman of
ovian scrutiny and i'll come in and say
what i've got to say after that
thank you for that council channel
councillor bell thank you very much
councillor channel that was much
appreciated
really just yes as the chair of overview
and scrutiny to
reiterate what councillor siddal said we
now have a firm
process for overview and scrutiny with
the submissions of the form
the working group and then items being
taken forward
now i think that's uh quite a robust
process we shall see but i believe this
is and i'm confident that this process
will meet the needs of overview and
scrutiny
much better than having set meetings on
set dates
which uh which actually is impractical
really i believe in
in this situation thank you
thank you very much and councillor
channel
um thank you very much chairman i'm just
underlining what council siddal did say
that it was a
working group set up by council so of
course it reports but
there's ways that things can get
reported to pga i'm sure
just to say on the ovien scrutiny and i
think it's been made clear i hope so
i believe every member can actually come
up with something they'd like to go to
over your scrutiny not just the over
scrutiny members
but also i think this might have
originated as further thinking
i don't sit on over in scrutiny um in
recent times
but i think when councillor helm was in
the chair um
the meeting might have been i think the
meeting prior to the annual a little
while before
i think there was a report from cheryl
hughes i think it was cheryl hughes's um
report about a working group and i think
it was agreed to overscooting that time
to have the working group function and
do it in that way
and i think this is just adding on to
that to make sure the working group
reports back so there's meat on the bone
when the items that the committees
looked at they've got something
to discuss in quite detail that was my
understanding when i sat on the working
group so hence why
part of that working group agreed with
this recommendation
sort of coming forward okay
thank you very much um tara has anybody
else indicated they wish to speak
no chairman thank you okay
uh in that case i'll i'll go to
thank you councillor siddall thank you
in that case i'll go to the
recommendations
uh that are in the report recommendation
one is that the remote meeting protocol
updates are revised by the corporate
governance working group
and set out in appendix say be adopted
are we happy to agree that by ascent
[Music]
thank you sorry guys i don't agree
if we need to have a roll call sorry i
can't agree on that
um chair is all i can say is that we all
know
this is aimed at me and uh this is
overreach and censorship
so i don't agree sorry if we've got a
roll call i'm more than happy to have my
descent
just minuted thank you
i i don't think constitutionally we can
do that tara can we
uh no chairman that is right the
procedure does say that if we have
dissent then we should be taking a roll
call
and we could take recommendations
together or separately i don't know
which members would prefer
okay um i'll what i'll do is i'll i'll
i'll
go with the other three first of all but
i think on this particular oh i say yeah
we can take them all together whether
you agree or not
okay so on our members happy to agree
all four recommendations um
subject to councillor morris's dissent
yes
agreed thank you for that
in that case we'll go for the roll call
then tara
so the roll call just to agree all the
recommendations as set out in the report
i've said it out in the report yes
please thank you starting with
councillor bassinger please
could you indicate four against or
abstain thank you
four please thank you councillor miss
beale
thank you that's the brian deal four
thank you councillor bell four can you
cancel mrs channel
oh thank you councillor edwards
for the councillor fluker
you know we may have i know he's having
problems with connectivity chairman so
it looks like he's dropped out okay um
counselor heard
uh i'm four counselor hull
thank you council jarvis
i'm four thank you tara thank you
councillor keys
i'm four thank you cancer logan
tara thank you that's the maze
four tara you councillor morley
thank you castle morris
against thank you councillor none
four please tara it counts to shauna c
four tara please cue cancer siddle
for thank you cancer schemes in two
minds
abstain
four please tara cancer stilts
paul please tara thank you cancer
swain oh thank you council mrs thompson
oh thank you and council miss white
four please tara thank you tell me the
results of that are twenty one four one
against and one abstention
thank you very much thank you very much
and uh
your uh dissension has been duly noted
councilors
thank you uh we'll move on to
agenda we'll move on to
agenda item 14 which is the rural
settlements list
and we're asked to approve this this is
found on pages 183
in a moment i'll call on the leader to
present this item
once again members please remember to
use the chat function
and i will come to you in turn
um leader can you present this report
please
yes certainly chairman thank you chair
the purpose of this
this report um is to propose a rural
settlement list for the financial year
2020
to 2021 to determine and award
rural rate relief it's very difficult to
say this chairman to be honest there's
only one line but my goodness it's a
tooth twister to award rural
rate relief to eligible businesses
chairman um just me
i don't think anybody needs to go to uh
mr leslie i think but uh if any members
want to that's
obviously up to you chair thank you
thank you yes mr leslie
yes thank you for having me to speak uh
chairman
uh i did just want to uh point out
to members that actually in the main
body of the report
um the years quoted they're actually
year out of date for example at
paragraph 1.1 this year should be 2021
22 rather than 20 20 21
however the date in the appendix which
has 2021 in it
uh which is seeking the approval is
actually correct so
that part is fine so apologies
for that okay thank you very much well
the recommendation
members is that the rural settlement
list attached as
appendix a b approved uh if any member
wants to second that motion
thank you councillor mays uh i will now
invite members to make any comments on
the report
tara has anyone indicated that they wish
to speak
uh yes chairman councillor stampers
asked to speak um yeah thank you
it was really just an apology to mr
leslie because actually he did tell me
there was an error and i forgot to
actually say that so thank you mr leslie
for assisting us i appreciate your help
thank you for that any other speakers
tara
and no chairman no one else has
indicated they wish to speak thank you
thank you very much so the
recommendation is
that uh the uh report is approved a
member is happy to do that by ascent
yes agreed three three agreed
agreed agreed
thank you very much indeed uh the next
item is agenda item
15 which relates to the resignation of
councillor elaine bamford and the
associated
vacancies so as we move to this
agenda item which is found on page 187
uh i would also draw members attention
to the addendum in relation to this
report
previously circulated and found on pages
13 and 14 of the supplementary pack
i'll call on the leader again to present
this item in a moment
again members if you wish to speak
please use the chat function
thank you leader thank you mr chair and
obviously the purpose of the report is
to deal with the associated vacancies
following the resignation
of councillor elaine bamford as a
district councillor
uh there's nothing more to say it's very
self-explanatory uh
chairman
indeed it is uh so the recommendations
are uh that the
council agrees appointments to the
working group and outside body
outside body positions and they are
as as stated there if any member wishes
to second that motion
uh could you please turn on your video
and state your name absolutely
thank you council and i think councillor
may's got there just slightly before you
um i think this is fairly
straightforward but if any members wish
to make any comment has anybody
indicated they wish to speak torah
no chairman no one's indicated they wish
to speak thank you
thank you so can i take it members that
you're happy to agree
all of those recommendations for the
working parties and groups
i assent a great degree please
agree to
thank you very much indeed uh agenda
item 16
which is uh uh schedule of meetings
uh this is found on page 191 uh
i will call on the leader to present
this item shortly
um once again please use the chat
function
thank you leader
thank you chair obviously the purpose of
this report
is that the draft schedule of meetings
for the 21-22
municipal year is presented for the
council's consideration
additionally the proposed updated
schedule for 20
20 21 to reflect budget deadlines is
provided for consideration
this one's another straightforward one
chairman so thank you
indeed it is uh the recommendation is
that the schedule of meetings for
2122 and the updated schedule
uh be approved uh if any member wishes
to
recommend the maze uh second that
thank you councillor mays uh any members
uh wish to make any comments on that
please tara
no chairman no one's indicated wish to
speak on that one
thank you very much so the
recommendation is that the
uh the schedule of meetings are approved
can we take that
by a cent a great
agreed thank you very much members uh
agenda item 17
this is business by reason of special
circumstances considered by the chairman
to be urgent i have none we then move to
agenda item 18 which is exclusion of the
public and press
therefore i move that the committee
resolves that under section 100 a4
of the local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following items of business
on the grounds that they involve the
likely disclosure
of exempt information as defined in
paragraph
three of part one of schedule 12a
to the act and that this satisfies
the public interest test is that
seconded
second thank you very much
indeed tara if you could just tell me
when the public streaming has stopped
uh chairman we just need
yes a member's happy
thank you very much
you